I like this not elude i was
very interested in the fact
that i wanted equality equality and
parenting and shared parenting and all
that we had a commitment
to that those notions.
I found that with young children
that wasn't necessarily the case
and there was a sad sort of
thinking back to the notion of it
that the mother would look
after the children and that
that you know men would go out
and be active in the world
and so it's very building my own house was
a really interesting consummate to start
negotiating that i was going on to
say look i don't want to anyway.
Undermine the importance and the
joy of nurturing young children.
It wasn't in any way for me a
need to move away from sally
and join a bit more to
play my rights to equality
and to encourage others to
particularly challenging
that to participate in equal parenting.
And you know i think
that that's a whole other dialogue the
importance of nurturance of young children
and you know i think the longer
that they really truly nurtured kept
away from institutions like school.
Anyway building the house. So i
decided to build a house so i did.
And i got tremendous support
from my extended family.
I had virtually no money
and well i got tremendous
support for my extended family
and great support from sally and
joan oh yes i mean john salley
and john were very helpful they used to
help me sort through the veranda boards
and through the you know the things i
learned i learned to see me in a different
light to many other children i think
that their mother was a builder
and their mother was active in providing
around shelter and things like that
and i loved building. I found that
i love the activity of building.
I found it very i found it very liberating
if i can use that fairly abused word.
Because i really came into my own power.
I could make all my own decisions.
Myself. I could have this
building exactly as i wanted it.
I could build in whatever way
i wanted. And i can do it.
It really wasn't so difficult
and it really was for me the beginning of
a lot of debunking of maleness i think
you know medicine's been very owned by me
and i think education's been
very owned by men and i think.
Shelter has been very own my
mean i say in recent times.
Of course because traditionally and
i'm talking about you know hundreds
and thousands of years ago. Women have
been all of those things the healers
and the witches. The educators and
the builders. And the gardeners.
So it's great for me to do
that because it was really in keeping
with my feminist growing feminist ideas
and ideology and.
A lot of support from my friends
that help me to be very organized
like a lot of the people on the farm
or several of the people on the farm
would come and help me on a saturday
and i would just organize
everything get everything
and then i just use this again generously
donated labor to put all the pieces you
know put the pieces of the jigsaw puzzle
together and tidy it up the next day
and go for it was just great. I loved it.
Many of my women friends came and
helped and then started coming
and asking how do you do this to
imagine how do you do that and i die.
They tell them what i knew which i learnt
from other builders watching other
buildings being built running down
every friday afternoon at 5 o'clock
and consulting bill chart of the local
buildings like how much space do you need
around we know how many millimeters do
you leave you know in the gap for a law
and various things like that.
So i'd gain my get my knowledge from
books and from people and some builders
and everywhere i could and then
i was really happy to pass
that information on again. I thought i
mentioned earlier i really believe that for.
All information is liberation in
a way or is the way to growth.
So i thought there was no reason
that i should hold this disinformation
secret to myself and still
and become part of the masons type club.
So i would be happy to pass that
information onto women and then.
So many women started asking me that how
do you do this or how do you do that.
I thought i had this run a
women's building course i think
that might sound very
presumptuous and bold
but you know we decided to start a school.
Primary school so
that our kids could be educated in animal
caring loving creative way so we done
that and i thought well you know
start a school what you know
and in course of the kids why not start
and i've been teaching carpentry in joinery
in the school to kids particularly
interested in teaching
the young girls skills.
So i sort of fronted up to
the local type of college
and sort of like to run a building
course for women. I think of it.
And they were rather you know the chap there
would like everyman was rather foolish
shocked and surprised and scratch his
head and. So i did. And that was great.
That was and i ran building courses for
women for many years not full time.
But every time i felt there was a need
within any community like the newman
community or broader other communities and.
Once i gathered enough women together.
It wasn't that i gather them the
sort of the interest would start to.
Sort of similar and i tell will gather a
group of you 12 to 20 women around you
and when you think you've got the
numbers will approach the college
and we were very lucky it was in those
days of supporting women's education
and in fact encouraging women's education
particularly nontraditional so-called
non-traditional areas.
So i was very lucky to continue to
be able to get funding to do that
and in later years i've gone on to run a
couple of courses which were not funded by
the state government institute.
Mission all government institutions
but funded privately by women.
In fact that so that's been fun.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yep it's spot on.
There was a lot of there was a lot of it.
Chauvinism i suppose we called
it chauvinism in those days
that were double my tended
to stop using i think.
And yes the notion of barefoot and
pregnant for women in long frocks as well.
Was prevalent. I mean it
was one of the issues
that i really felt uncomfortable about i
didn't necessarily feel uncomfortable
about it within my own households fear
because we had some fairly strong women in
that household and we all had our
deficiencies and now major hang ups
and things like that
but basically we encouraged each other
in our full you know full pursuit of our
interests. But yeah that that was very
it still alarms me it still horrifies me
that in the so-called
alternative society that
that there is such male
chauvinism to use that word.
There are such disrespect
for women's equal rights.
I mean you know we still live in a
society where women don't get equal pay.
You know women still get something like
67 per cent of the male average wage.
You know that's the broader
community and i don't think
that the alternative society as you know
based nimbin did very much for women's
rights that way at all. I know that a
lot of women have gained their power
and gone ahead and built houses and fixed
cars and been leaders of communities and.
Community leaders
and even have fortunately now three women
in this small city council who are older
women.
Even though they called all the men
still i mean those things have occurred
but i don't really even see the still very
much shift of consciousness amongst most
of the population around women's rights.
It's you know this is this this sort of.
This sickness that strikes relationships.
Quite often when people you know
heterosexual couples have children.
And it's sort of like i have this notion
about radical talk about my notion of
radicals many of us were radicals were
seen as radicals we were quite radical we
were doing radically different
things and one of my notions
or one of my theories about radicals
is that. Come a certain age time.
And it's often around about 30. People
who are radical in their youth.
Sort of get confronted with this.
Energy wave or something
and i go oh my god of i still got to keep
making up the rules for myself about
relationships about equality about
work about social issues or
that sort of thing and it just sort of
you know the sort of a certain city.
Sometimes hits people about that age
and i think a lot of people who have been
radical choose to continue to be radical
and you know you see i see us
i mean i'm not 60 or 70 yet
but you know i hope i'm still fairly
alert and prepared to change at
that age 80 90 i have this vision of
me still there doing that 90 hopefully
and i hope everybody kicks me along
particularly the kids to do that.
And so i think some people stay radical
and are prepared to live quite a difficult
life at times because you have to keep
making up the rules there are no appropriate
role models anywhere in the world you
know i mean russia's crumbled
and it was never it never got to you know
treat women equally or anything like
that. So there's nowhere
really that we see
that as our there's no role models for
us so we have to keep making it up.
I have to keep making up how to
parent my teenage children in a way
that i hope will be.
Lead to us having a long long term
loving relationship with each other.
And so we have to make it up
and i'm prepared to do that
but it takes a lot of energy
that takes a lot of time
and it takes a lot of research
and reading and talking
and actually my god you have to actually
talk with people about these ideas you
know you can't take anything
as given. Right. And here.
Sally and joan are giving a perfect example
of sisterly brotherly love very nice.
Thank you very much. And there are others
that you get hit by this energy
wave if you will to go out to her.
Basically i mean a conscious decision
quite often for these people
and who basically have come from
very conservative backgrounds
and our radic those red people's radical
years have been a reaction against
conservatism and basically it's
easier just to follow the model
that my dad called grandma
grandpa whoever it is set
and a lot of you know our great an esteemed
radical leaders of the time of sunk
back into what i would consider
considered to be fairly conservative.
Ways i mean i want to decide boring there
but there's a real value
judgment isn't it.
You know and i try not to be too
but it looks to me like these people are
actually not particularly stimulated
that's what i mean about
boring. They seem bored.
They seem fairly unstimulated
and seem to spend a lot of time
and energy trying to make life look very
exciting doing essentially great time
consuming that fairly unstimulating thing.
That's about radicals.
I've never been very radical
but maybe i don't know.
I sometimes don't think i'm ready
when other people say you know.
I don't know the answer
that i don't really care.
I just hope i keep growing and changing
and i hope people keep boot
me along the way to do it.
You know i'm still constructing
you to constructing utopia.
Oh i don't think i'd be as.
Arrogant to say that i know.
No that life can be pleasant. I know
that life can be fulfilling interesting.
I know it can be so i can my life can be
surrounded by people who are loving found
stimulating interesting. I know
the environment can be beautiful.
I mean that's one of the other things
that i've been passionately involved with
and that's for the protection
of the environment.
And it was a whole other
area i suppose so.
I think that i'm i still am i
trying to create a utopia.
I think utopia exists in the way i
mean the other world is beautiful.
Humans are beautiful other
species are beautiful.
All we have to do is actually get away
from our egocentric selves in a way
and be generous and be
willing to move over and let
that shine around us. Really
i know that sense now.
So that's why i'm a hippie because i say
things like that's really cosmic far out
man. You know i'm i'm quite i'm
quite spiritual in that except to
that extent. I always
have been i think. And.
Still seems if you got to
have a sense of humor.
I mean you know i take
myself very seriously.
You know i take myself very seriously.
I take my humor very seriously as a wonderful
t-shirt a friend of ours on the farm
used to read which really used to
stir so many people and it said.
I am a humorless feminist
and i mean i just need to get such a
chuckle every time and wore that t shirt
and
and women.
When i was because i can talk
about home birth number 7.
And jonah all of the greek commonly known
as bones. Cause i can talk about that.
Now look at my lovely daughter salim i
can also talk about her birth which was.
Beautiful through. It's like telling. Sex.
As long as i have a little bit about
your dressing and i will. Ok.
I decided to have a my second child for
we decided to have our second child at
selling john's dad and i and we decided
to have that child at home to have
that birth at home and so we went
about gaining support for that.
Now i might add here that i lived at
that time with people who were involved
in the medical psychology social work
professions
and they want to clean about it was a bit
of a freak out the idea of having a baby
at home i was very clear part of having
a baby at home for me was about taking
responsibility for myself and for my life.
And that's what a lot of my
whole life has been about
and that's what i want him
has been so wonderful.
I've had
that opportunity to take responsibility for
all aspects of my life so i was prepared
to take responsibility for the
birth of my second child and by
that i meant i was prepared to make decisions
around how it would be who would be
there. What i do.
The usual fears that any any.
Pregnant woman goes through and father is
you know what if the child is deformed
or not normal or dead or you know but
basically if it's if it's a deformed.
What will i do and i was very
clear about that i'd gone through
that with self birth i had made the doctor
who was my birth of systems at her birth
made him promise
that if my child my first born child
was born with obvious growth physical
disabilities
that would require gross amounts of medical
intervention to continue to sustain the
life of that child that he
would promise he wouldn't take
that medical intervention.
Now you know he quoted hippocratic
oath to me and all sorts of things.
But finally i got him to do that.
I mean you know that was a very big thing
and it was a turning point in his career
he said for me for him to actually realize
that it was not against the hippocratic
oath to let women take responsibility for
their birthing process to that extent.
So i was prepared to take
those responsibilities
and make those decisions around
the birth of my second child.
And i made that very clear to
our extended family members so
that they didn't feel
responsibilities that.
As for example the doctor in our
household felt might fall his way
or thought is due. So we went
about having a baby at home
and you know creating the nest
getting carol stannard carol.
Norman stannard and dorothy smith to
be a support team actually midwife
and support team.
And i went into the labor
and john it was born.
Was a beautiful birth. It was full moon.
Hackles in the capitol
for full moon in scope.
You know they well there's
one for the australia did
and there were nine people at jonah's
birth. Cell of course was their cell was.
Twenty three months old.
Nearly two at that time
and she had her loving other mother
beth with her as her support person.
We work sela john was one of six
thirty eight in the morning
and went into labor about 12
that night the night before and
when it was obvious that
the baby was coming soon.
Sally was woken up
and there she was able to see her
brother brought into the world.
She knew all about the physicality of
intercourse birth motorist everything.
Again you know knowledge is
power or something like that.
So she was totally aware
of what was happening.
She knew where jonah was
going to come out and
that the might be blood the might be water
all of those things so i don't think
your particular phase certainly
didn't seem to be that it
and you know i have this image of sally
in her little red dressing gown with the.
Ladybird that
and down the front the held
lovingly by my my sister beth
as jonah came into the world. I mean.
And they were these nine people who fell
in love with this baby as he literally
popped out put his little hand
out grabbed carol's finger
and came into the world
and then the rest of the family the rest
of the farm came within minutes of his
birth and all flocked around
and do garden or rest
and i mean what i want to say about
that was that it was just so wonderful.
The experience with sally had
been sure to be my first birth
and then in hospital i felt
very isolated i was the only.
Woman who was demand feeding her child
in this hospital environment then i
discovered this one other woman.
Fortunately who'd had six children
and who actually taught me
how to demand feed my child
and i learned how to demand food much of
that is you had to get the nurses
to bring that child to you
when the child woke up
and cried because we weren't allowed to
have our babies next to us during the night
that was a trauma for me.
All i want was my baby next to me and i
would be all right thank you very much.
So the experience was that
from that was i learned
that i really wanted my baby with
me when it was born. Thanks.
After i was born
and so that's what one of the reasons
i chose to have it journal time and.
It was wonderful because like i'd gone to
bed the night before i'd gone into labor.
I'd had a baby at 6:30 8:00 in the morning
i got up afterwards and had a shower.
I'd run the family in sydney at about 8
o'clock a lovely little baby boy you know.
And i'd gone back rested for the rest of
the day but i wandered around you know
when said a lot of the goats and the
cows and the chooks and the case
and the ducks and the vegie garden
and i mean just seemed to me
that home birth was just a part of life
instead of being this great big you know
that it was really very eventful. But
my life went on as well. Very easily.
I wasn't estranged
or taken away from my daughter she was
there she sort of sat there and held him
and touched him and pushed and
probe and tasted like rim.
Sell putting a what does it taste like.
I will taste him
and find out she sort of you know i
mean that's not the sort of thing
that can happen in a
hospital and. Very nice.
I think so because i mean a
new baby taste delicious.
Oh this just this beautiful
succulent little new being you know
and so all of those things would have
felt like a continuation of my life.
Normally and. It was lovely.
It was wonderful and from
that i decided well there aren't enough
of these women have a visit home so we
formed the birth of beyond group.
We'd formed and i think just before.
You know about the time i'd have to look
up the dates very much around journalists
the carol and others formed us and beyond
and we decided we'd help as
many families as we could
and to have their babies in the
manner in which they chose so that if
that meant supporting a woman to
have a child in hospital we do
that if it meant supporting a woman
through as much of her labor at home
and then it being necessary
for her to go to hospital
or being her choice to
go to hospital would do
that if it meant choosing to
have a baby at home we do that.
So i started to learn
midwifery skills and you know
that involved taking risks
and we were paid to do it
and we had to negotiate with the medical
profession in lismore of course to be have
them as our support people when
we didn't know what to do or
when we didn't count the difficulties
or difficult the things like that
and we had to face. You know
charges are irresponsible.
I don't think it's irresponsible
to have your baby at home.
I think is a very responsible act.
So it was a guide it was one of those
very powerful times for me i grew a lot
through that experience.
I loved helping women have their
babies at home it was a real honor.
It's an honor to be around.
It's an honor to be around this
and in later times i've moved towards
helping friends towards their death
and it's been. You know it's reclaiming.
The rights to all aspects of our lives.
It's reclaiming the right to
have control over our lives to.
God shelter to provide education to
provide food to provide birthing
and death in a way that we
that we want to do it.
How long was i in then.
Gee i don't even like putting years over
that you know i was in nimbin for some
of the most formative years of my life.
And
and i'm grateful for the experience of
having been there i think it was something
like 11 years i lived in then and because
you see i lived community in the city
and it was all it's all part
of the continuum isn't it.
Where am i now you know i
mean i live at the beach
but i still see myself as
part of an extended family.
So i lived in them then at the
same time same community and
when my partner charlie and
i met and fell in love.
We lived part time at kind of all falls
and part time nimbin trying to work out
how we would negotiate the physicality of
our you know where would
we have our domicile.
But mainly i lived i stayed at paradise i
never moved on from there till we left
and it was great. Like.
So although it was 11 years short
it was you know have a lot of money
or something and i don't know and
i don't really know how to put
that in terms of in words because i'm
just grateful for that experience
and in a way i've never left him and.
I live it's you know in a beautiful
environment on the beach now and.
But you know it's like it's
still part of the still
when i think of home that's part of my
concept of home i mean i have very many
when i think of home many parts of
the world in a way fit into that
that image for me now and then
certainly a large part of
that i've still got thoughts of defense
they still have contact they have recently
been involved in teaching a course
to teenagers their. It's not.
I mean i don't even think
that you have to leave places
and that's part of what i think i learnt.
Living at nimbin is that you can
have these connections and bonds
and you know never have to leave
you just not there at the moment.
But of how that attitude. Why did i.
And why did i move away from nimbin might
be a better way of putting that question.
And that's that's a very long answer in the
way it was after a long time of living
in one place i think i was
really ready for a change.
And i become in over the years more
and more involved in women's education.
And i think a lot of the issues of
women's equality haven't been addressed.
Or hadn't been addressed by most
of the members of the community.
And one of the difficult issues that
we went through were issues of.
Incest within the family.
I didn't feel
that our family adequately our extended
family adequately addressed those issues to
the satisfaction
and to the to the recovery of the young
children involved young women involved.
And i really you know that was
that was part of my i'd already moved to
the coast for work work was one of the
reasons.
Some of the issues
that care of the environment were certainly
involved some of the disagreements
within the community about how we would
actually care for this very beautiful
environment and it wasn't
that i was opposed.
I think it was just as
when i think in particular i
think i was ready for a change
and i was ready to try to be in a situation
where again i could be in a situation
where i could have.
Control over some of the important choices
i don't mean control in a negative way
more in the gaining power by
being responsible. Your choices.
I'm not saying this very
well it's a bit muddled.
So i might have to rephrase some of this.
Some of the reasons that i
moved away from them then.
Involved moving to a place
where we could but charlie
and i were able to find for work more
easily without long distances of travelling
and i was really ready for change.
I think after a long period of
commitment to community living.
At paradise valley
and still love living community
in an extended family.
I wanted to be able to be in a situation
where some of the social issues
that are really important to me were
really being fully addressed within my own
household and some of those issues
for me. Issues of addiction.
I really want to live in a drug free
household for myself and for the kids.
I want to live in a you know situation
where people really are prepared
and brave enough to take on social issues
like dealing with incest which wasn't
adequately dealt with in my view in the
community and. Issues of the environment.
And i don't i don't think we were able
as a group to come together very well
and make really significant. Radical.
Decisions about care of the
environment and those were the things
that were sort of happening at the time
that i was really ready to make my move.
And as those issues became difficult i
mean you asked whether some life there was
very difficult because it was
difficult trying to not all of
that up with you know many different
people from different backgrounds
and different ideologies
and we didn't have any bonding ideology
you didn't have to pass a test to come
there. So as that i think that some
of those issues were quite difficult
and i was i guess a little wearied
of putting in such intense energy
constantly on some of those issues.
And education was one of the issues
that that was involved in my move
and the kids dad wasn't particular.
Satisfied with the notion of them continuing
high school sorts of education at
nimbin and so charlie
and i decided to be in a situation where
the availability of high schools would be
more acceptable to their dad
and you know to make life easier easier
for the kids hopefully so there were all
these various issues that came into it.
And one of the issues was
that we were ready to travel with the
kids would promise the kids we'd take two
or charlie promised the kids
he'd take them to america
and disneyland before salvage 12 and sally
very sort of wisely reminded charlie.
Some 12 month or two years before
that you get i'm nearly 12
and you have this promise.
So we actually had to make sure that
we could earn our income earners
and i think come to to take these wild
adventure of you know just heading off
overseas for half a year
or so. So all of those.
And influenced me
and you know i just i just saw my moving
on from nimbin a bit as being just another
opportunity for me to grow in other
ways and to take a lot of the learning
that i have learnt from an indian
out into the broader community.
I mean you know like we were looking
after our environment through the forest
campaigns that i was very intimately
involved with and things like
that we were doing some of
that we've got we've got the rainforest
policy for new south wales establish we've
got the multiple occupancy changes in
local government occur and things like
that we do stablish schools
but here we were you know across byron bay
he's an environment still being ravaged
so you know part of what i've done since
being out here is to establish with others
and environments into here and
you know things like that.
So you know it's just an opportunity to go
and expand somewhere else.
Oh oh.
What a question the question being what
made the community ineffectual with dealing
with child abuse. Patriarca
all patriarchal overlay.
Yeah. You want me to repeat it.
Like what made it made it what.
Why was the community ineffectual in dealing
with child abuse within the community.
I wish i really knew the answer to
that i can only i'm still
only guessing at some of that
and it's very easy to
make generalizations.
I think one of the reasons the community
wasn't effective in dealing with child
abuse was that many of the
men in the community.
Most of the men in the community.
Basically felt it was okay and i'm
really saddened to have to say that.
I don't think
that very many men were prepared to
look at their own sexuality their own
objectification of women and children.
And to come to make some growth steps
through that i think many of the men felt.
Oh yeah. But i've been a bit like
that myself. Therefore it must be ok.
I don't think there were very many women
who were brave enough to speak out against
their partners although in
private conversations with me.
Many of the women would when it came to a.
Confrontation situation
which it indeed was.
Those women were too threatened
about their relationships i think.
And that's that's
when we talked earlier about sexism within
communities we didn't used to call it
sexism but i think that the
print appropriate word to use.
I don't think issues of sexism have been
dealt with in individual communities
or the community at large and
i'm very saddened by that
and i can only do that myself and it.